[Music]
hello everyone we are here in los
angeles california for key 3 aka summer
game fest summer game mess fake e3
whatever you want to call it uh but
we're very excited to be back doing
stuff in person i'm lucy james joining
me is tamar hussein hello and will biles
director over at supermassive games here
to talk about the quarry will thank you
so much for joining us you are welcome
uh what is it like i mean let's ask the
question just because before we were
recording we were talking about covid
how difficult it made things the quarry
not only a game pretty much developed
during
the dark types but also you know you've
got this amazing cast
what's it been like to pull something so
ambitious together
you know it was really it was genuinely
a challenge we started really before
covert kind of kicked off
proper so uh yeah so we we started off
that we got it going and then and then
covered kicked in right when we were
about to start the main main kind of
shoot
um so that kind of put the kibosh on
that quite badly so we went and talked
to the u.s embassy um
i had to go to switzerland to uh to get
a special dispensation to come over um
that took a number of weeks to try and
just get that sorted and then uh
the screen actors guild over here in
america they'd set up a bunch of
protocols already for the movie industry
and we were able to shoot under very
very strict um conditions we all had to
be tested every day this was pre uh
vaccine so no one was vaccinated so it
was a little bit it was definitely
challenging it was a it was a hurdle but
actually ultimately it was fine you know
it was it's you kind of you kind of run
up against this stuff and as long as as
long as you you can you know people put
the effort in i think it was all worked
out to them seems to have been worth the
effort obviously reviews are now out
there and largely positive um
an interesting kind of like i wouldn't
say an upswing but
more
more kind of like a concrete positive
than
previous project coming out the studio
like super massive did man of medan and
prior to that was until dawn um what do
you think it is about that kind of genre
because the two genres that seem to be
resonating most with people are the kind
of slasher flick teen thing whereas the
man of madame stuff is a little more
divisive and it's also a little bit more
like experimental what do you think
about those two games and that genre is
really resonating with people and why is
it that you as a studio seem to one
chase that genre and also be very good
at doing that genre
uh thank you no i think i i think
there's a
there's a likeness to teen horror that
so the dark pictures are kind of more of
a dark
i i wouldn't say adult horror although
they are kind of there's a there's a
wider range of stories so they can go in
and out of lots of different stories
whereas teen horror is really very
specifically
kind of cliched it's it everyone knows
what it is there's a familiarity to it i
think um there's there's also a
lightness to it that's um i don't even
like this as in kind of it's just
just there's it's it kind of peaks and
troughs through humor a little bit it's
not comedy by any means but there's but
it doesn't take itself very seriously
and that's kind of on purpose and i
think that's part of teen horror as well
that's that's and it's really part of
teen horror since the scream franchise
started uh and even scary movie and
stuff like that um there was a there's a
definite kind of um self-awareness to it
that i think people kind of buy into a
little bit and also there's a rule set
to teen horror you kind of you know the
the rules you know these are
transgressive rules and stuff i mean we
don't really lay into that stuff now
because it's kind of a bit dated but it
but it's a starting point and i think so
i think that's where the biggest
difference comes from it's just kind of
the tone i think
so you mentioned there
you mentioned scream scary movie you
also mentioned the rules how fun is it
to kind of use those as like touch
points but then get to subvert and play
around within that right brilliant it's
so yeah i mean that's that's that's
really good fun i mean we kind of start
off with like a a fairly standard
standard like a movie script it's like a
kind of 90-page script um and that's
that's the kind of
starting point and if we if we get that
right and we think that's a good story
and there's a and you know people read
it and they kind of are drawn in by it
then we start breaking that down into
the um into the branching side of stuff
and every single point along the way is
a kind of what if and as long as we're
thinking within the context of a set of
rules that you know teen horror people
are really really familiar with then we
can really muck about with that and
you're right sometimes we subvert it
sometimes it's uh sometimes it's
sometimes we put it you know really
really nail it on the head there's a
there's a scene in this game that we
kind of also had in until dawn where
uh a character comes across a trapdoor
it's kind of super obvious you come
across a trap door that's banging
and you think well
what do you think is going to if you
open that trapdoor what do you think is
going to happen uh and we did it in in
uh in until dawn you know there was a
dead friend that the person who is dead
this dead friend is calling them and
they walk down and you choose to walk
down you don't have to and they get to
the banging trap door and you choose to
open the trap door and again you don't
have to and if you do you get killed
straight away so we we said you know
let's just put it straight back into
into the quarry see what happens and
again people still need to actually even
we even verbally warn you she the the
the the character says if i open that
chapter i am going to die straight away
i guess the the kind of interesting
thing from a narrative perspective is
movies that you're inspired by like
scream and the other slasher flicks they
they have a very specific run time and
it allows them to control the way things
unfold and pacing and that kind of stuff
whereas you know you're now making
another 10 ish hour plus game how does
that impact how you're writing these
stories because you know orchestrating
tension is hard enough but then
orchestrating tension and also having
character arcs that travel across 10
hours what's that like to come up with
well to be honest we use a little bit of
uh of trickery really with that um it's
it's we kind of
steal it really from the kind of stephen
king style of writing where there's a
big story but actually you're kind of
jumping between characters so we don't
have a long linear story although we
definitely start that way we're we have
it's more like a spoked wheel and each
one of the each one of the characters
has a
has a journey towards a a
a convergence
so that means we can kill them whenever
we like and the story still stays whole
we don't you we don't you as you know we
don't suddenly you don't go back and go
oh i'll save i'll do a save before this
person gets killed and restart because
that kind of ends up in very very
stunted cul-de-sacs because people just
go i don't look dead i'll go back and do
that
and we want the story to change with
with kind of that and have the jeopardy
of death as well that kind of that idea
that this is if i make this choice i
might actually you know this character
might disappear off my story so we have
these kind of spoke weird this spoked
wheel of story um arcs and each
character has a kind of a kind of
douchey arc and a kind of a more of a
heroic arc and again it's just down to
you um also the characters are by nature
in these things a little bit kind of
douchey to start off with anyway they're
just you know they're not lovable
characters i mean they're not horrible
either they're just flawed people but
you know douchebags are the heart gold
yes exactly yeah and and it's entirely
up to you about how you bring that out
if they survive
but how difficult is that i mean you've
explained it in a way that it makes
sense in my brain but you know
when you think of the various
permutations you can possibly get the
fact that characters can die and how
many endings i think i've read somewhere
it's like over 100 almost 200 186 i
think it is a lot of endings that's
terrifying amount of endings making me
i'm just just thinking about that
well so it's the way the way to see it
is
so so stories are really difficult to
it's very it would be really easy to
write a single story and make 100
endings by just going well this this one
on alien lands and this one uh they end
up in hawaii suddenly and you know so
so that's not how the kind of endings
work it's much more about the idea that
these stories change and the journey is
really important it's like um it's like
uh i could walk over to that um tv and
that would be the and that's the story i
get up and walk over to the tv i could
also get up and walk over the tv and
push the camera over as i go past please
don't do that i won't do that i won't do
that but that's that changes quite a lot
of it's not a huge change in the story
but it's like wow that was very
different or you know there's a whole
bunch of different versions of that i
still always end up at the tv so it's
not always about the end and what we did
is um with these kind of nine characters
and these nine journeys and all the
deaths that they can have and all the
versions of other things that can go on
whilst they're going through that we
wanted to make sure that when you get to
the end it can be a little confusing
it's like well what the hell happened
there that person died i don't quite
remember why they did that and so we had
to write a little card for every single
character and every single end that that
character would have so that when the
game's finished we go to every single
character and go that happened to this
person that happened to this person and
we had to write 186 of them so so that's
how we know the number of endings on
that is just literally that number so
some of them will be okay well that was
that person died and that person died in
a different way but it so it's not like
again they're you know once suddenly
gets sent to hawaii yeah so
maybe there's no good answer this to
this but i feel like i should ask it but
like how has
the last few years the way people
consume
uh content whether it's tv shows movies
has changed quite significantly because
of the way you know the various
platforms exist like netflix and amazon
and also the fact that we're all
at home for a really long time how much
do you and until dawn and man of madan
and also the quarry are very filmic or
tv series experiences and that's
something you guys try to kind of
emulate and are inspired by how much are
you paying attention to the way people
consume other media like tv shows and
how much does that how does that inform
the way you make your series because it
is kind of like very there's a lot of
touchstones yeah yeah
the answer is a lot um you know so
you're right consumption of narrative is
an entirely different thing um available
to us now this we always had long form
but it was always meted out over a
weekly thing now you could just binge an
entire i do i mean you know i spend
entire weekends just going through maybe
two or three seasons of something
something you know it's just like um so
that level of um
of really big storytelling and a
character development and and kind of
the nature of um
the nature of arts going through big
arts smaller arts all that sort of stuff
is really is is something that we
weren't really particularly used to an
hour and a half film was a standard film
a three hour films like oh my god that's
an epic that's going to be you that was
testing people's patience that's nothing
now that's you know that's not a thing
so so that's really nice i really like
that it allows for it's funny when you
go back to a 90-minute film now
sometimes it's like oh that seems
especially if you've read a book or
something about it first and you look
and it's like it's so concise now and so
kind of like um uh
uh edited that it's like well you don't
need to do that now and i think i think
with um netflix and prime and all of
them really it's like you know that's
that's just become a stock and trade
though i suppose as well like kind of um
the way that people consume content over
twitch i mean i remember when i played
until dawn
you think typically hey it's a single
player game i'll play this by myself no
i played it with a friend at the time
and we would make those decisions
together and so obviously now even with
the quarry and with the dark pictures
it's like
you kind of went into it knowing that
people would do that yeah absolutely and
that's a really big part is that um
certainly with until dawn it was we kind
of started it as a date game kind of
date movie thing um and again this was
like six seven years ago
we are i mean we very purposely now have
gone this is a sofa game for couch play
it's about doing it with your friends i
actually weirdly played a bunch of it
with um with david arquette and
some of the cast the other day it's
hilarious that's that's where these
games really come into their own it's
genuinely a social experience and so you
could do it you know on the couch or
we've got an online version as well
where you know you could get up to eight
people playing together and it's and
it's just really about voting and it's
again even with like you say about
consumption of um of story and media and
narrative is now in netflix you can
share watching something so you know um
if i'm away i can i can share with my
family
watching the exact same thing at the
exact same time which sounds weird but
it's actually really cool as someone who
does that every week with love island
with my friends it doesn't sound weird
at all
it's funny it's like um the the
environments change the storytelling
environments change it's weirdly
actually it's much more like sitting
around a campfire and you know that
sharing of stories it's
especially spooky stories yeah i mean
what does that kind of method of
consuming the game
mean for you as developers like in my
mind or for a lot of people obviously
the idea that a bunch of people are
going to stream themselves
most people go well that just means that
you're kind of basically allowing a
group of people to have the free viewing
of this of this game what does that mean
for you as a studio um is that viable
long term can you continue to keep
making games knowing that
there's going to be a massive group of
people who aren't going to buy it
they're just going to watch other people
play it yeah i mean so we had i think on
until dawn i think the view count was
was over 2 billion wow i know i know
right so yeah so um so that's going to
happen and that's fine and you know what
i actually really like that i think
that's a really good thing
the real joy about this is not just the
story um there's like a film mode you
could just press play and just watch the
whole thing as a movie um and you could
kind of adjust that and you can set
parameters to change it and do lots of
stuff
and a lot of people will do that and a
lot of people who are not necessarily
gamers hopefully will do that and that
was kind of part about
the reason why we wanted to try and get
the tech really up and get the facial
and the
performance capture really really as
slick as possible because we wanted to
try and break that
um that that thing of the suspension of
this belief kind of interrupting a story
at least we're not 100 there yet it's
still you know it's still a burgeoning
tech but we did want to try and make
that happen there's no way you'll i
don't think anyone will ever see all of
it um there's so much i mean it's you
know it's a 10 hour thing there's 30
hours of of content and um and this
and it's it's sometimes it's just
contextual sometimes it's like you know
just a bit of um
and the context is like um so you have a
conversation
and um we could just be talking like we
are now
and as far as you're concerned i'm just
a normal bloke you know just over here
in l.a if you suddenly found out and
knew that i was a murderer
but your entire experience of this
conversation changes massively yeah play
for directing a game while also
murdering people yeah
on camera too yeah but you know what i
mean so and so that really changes stuff
so it's not just not just about the the
branching it's about the context of what
you know of what might have happened or
didn't happen or and that changes again
depends on how you play it so kind of
like a final one from me
uh
a lot of ways a lot of different ways
that people can die in the game
do you have a particular favorite
uh
so there's a an expression which is a
gross expression but to be honest we've
got a couple of d glovings
oh that is a that is grim oh god oh yeah
it is grim so yeah
i regret asking
at least now
i i'm interested as a kind of follow-up
also last question is
what did the kind of cost how did they
kind of take to it what was i imagine
for a lot of them like i don't as far as
i know david arquette isn't in many
games same for like ted raymie um so
what was it like for them to see as as
people who have been immersed in the
movie industry to see the thing that
they do now exist on in a different form
on tv like they must have been like oh
it's also a weird touchstone for them
right like it's a similar vibe like
david arquette is kind of doing like a
screamy thing but now it's in video
games what was it like yeah um did you
see him on jimmy kimmel the other night
watching himself with ariel winter oh i
didn't see yeah yeah oh yeah so that
yeah they're blown away by it
um
it was weird so so the younger actors
it's kind of split between the younger
actors who are kind of playing the teams
and the councillors and then the sort of
slightly older um
group who play the kind of the
the
the
well i was trying to think of the right
way the kill billies
expression
that's a great
um
and so you've got like lance henriksen
and lin shay and um and david arquette
and so they came on the set uh weirdly
lance uh lance had done stuff before so
um but um but they come on the set and
and they're used to cameras and they're
used to lights and they're used to kind
of the normal the film set and and
they're suddenly they're wearing a weird
like receipt with dots on and they've
got a helmet with a stereo camera here
and it's very abstract i mean we build
the entire set but it's very skeletal
it's kind of like you know they're like
doors are just frames and you can so you
can open it so that's all there but what
they can do is they can see there's the
big tvs they can see themselves in their
costumes 100 in character
um all lit um everything all the effects
going on so they don't so for the first
half a day they're all just dancing
around in front of the tv doing some
great outtakes
um
but then when they see themselves uh
once the facial goes in um and that
takes a little while that's all sort of
an ai based uh machine learning style of
doing the facial so that takes a number
of weeks for it to kind of go through
the iterations to get to kind of the
quality level we were after um once they
see that i mean they're they're just
blown away they're really blown away
like i said i was playing uh playing it
through the other day with them with a
group of them and they they're just
astounded and some of them
i mean
you know you guys are gamers and you
kind of you know the difference you know
what cg you know about the uncanny
valley you know about all that kind of
stuff but the people who are who are
unused to it is just like they just see
themselves it's like i don't remember
doing that shot i wasn't in a car
anyway so yeah it's uh yeah it's amazing
they love it awesome amazing well
looking forward to playing will thank
you so much for coming down super
welcoming yeah and when when's the
quarry out when can everyone play friday
so friday the 10th uh day after tomorrow
yeah
kind of
yeah
probably out now by the time you're
watching oh yeah okay yeah obviously
yeah and it's available pretty much
everywhere right yep yeah pc consoles
vlog awesome thank you thank you so much
yeah welcome and make sure to stay tuned
for more from summer game fest k3
whatever you want to call it we'll be
right here in l.a
you